la jolla thank you for another great
weekend it's one of my favorite places
to perform the la jolla comedy store you
guys are awesome
philadelphia i'll see you august 18th
through the 20th austin texas september
2nd through the 3rd that's labor day
weekend vancouver finally september 15th
through the 17th get your tickets to
those shows and all shows on my website
at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
stickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media and again i want to say
thank you thank you if you've been here
thank you if you're new here i
appreciate the support
please subscribe to the youtube if
you're watching hit that subscribe
button it really helps the show and if
you got to have more then you got to
check out the patreon it's called the
honeydew with y'all and i'm highlighting
the low lights with y'all and y'all got
the lowest low lights i've [ __ ] ever
heard all right it is never a letdown
and it's only five bucks a month if you
sign up for a year you get over a month
free and you're getting the honeydew a
day early ad free at no extra cost all
right if you or someone you know has
that story it's got to be heard then
you've got to send an email to us at
honeydewpodcast gmail.com hopefully
we'll get to do an episode together all
right the night pass nation tour
continues to roll on i can't thank you
all enough for that philly i will see
you all august 18th through the 20th
austin that's labor day weekend
september 2nd and 3rd vancouver
september 15th through the 17th in
edmonton september 29th through october
1st all right that's the biz right there
you all know we do over here we
highlight the low lights i always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers i am very excited to have
this guest here on the honeydew first
time here y'all please welcome kevin
clancy welcome to the honeydew sir it is
an honor brother i've heard that intro
so many times to see it in person is uh
it's quite the excitement it's an honor
to to have you say that i mean i i i the
way i say it the way i see it
i wanted to come on this podcast for
three main reasons number one
i could wear my night pants
i have some next door i'm another pants
guy
don't forget we gotta give him some like
i got a package coming your way i got it
i know what you're saying it's in the
car i picked it up this morning we got
our porch yeah we call it indoors
clothes so night pants soft clothes
indoors clothes whatever anywhere i can
wear these pants good to go
two
i gotta hear the laugh in person
i love it it's gonna be a beautiful
thing and three i genuinely think
this is the only podcast worth doing man
on a real level like there's a great
show how did you say this like you're on
nine although i'm like no no but that's
what i mean like there's so many good
shows so many funny shows people that i
i've grown to love and become fans of
and i will gladly do their show and we
will have a good time always
but i think this is the like the realest
show in the game where like
you know if you're going to talk about
some real [ __ ] you come here and do it
so uh i mean i i the the first
eight years of being a podcaster i never
listened to any podcast and i finally
started to listen to it when like you
know the whole industry blew up with
comics and everything and when i
stumbled on this one it's like you
always know you're gonna hear some real
[ __ ] it can be like interesting you know
deep combo you can get laughs anywhere
you know we can all have fun but this is
this is the real one so very happy to be
here dude thank you
i um you know it's funny you say that
because
i i rem i always was remembered people
buy some that sort of story about them
like some people like that guy drives a
trans am i like really did you know that
guy was in a [ __ ] house fire and
pulled nine people out you know right he
lost his mother
that's the [ __ ] i always was that got me
about someone i don't give a [ __ ] where
you live or what you drive or whatever
especially now you did what you get one
you become one thing known as one thing
on the internet one thing and you're you
know and that's it and meanwhile there's
stories on stories on stories on stories
you know and i've learned so many times
there's been guests who i'm like on my
show i'm like uh you know okay i'll do
that guest you know and they end up
being like
i'm like thank god i didn't pass because
it was the best story i've ever heard
the most interesting person i've ever
met you know it's like oh i knew i
thought he was that that actor from that
tv show [ __ ] that we didn't talk about
that we talked about you know his life
growing up and you know all these things
so everybody's got a story that's why
you know the the patreon honeydew works
it's like oh man i mean someone's coming
that was creepy bro
first when i sit here i'm like why
just you did what god bless the people
who tell the stories i'm like i would
take all of this [ __ ] to my grave all of
it yeah
and they're selling the world all of
them man before we record i told them
hey just because it's behind a paywall
man people screaming like if you don't
want to say it don't [ __ ] say no it's
going out there that's so true man
that's yeah
no really internet um please before we
get into uh whatever we're going to talk
about today plug plug it all yes sir uh
we got my we just hit my 10th
anniversary of my podcast kfc radio me
and my co-host uh john feitelberg you'll
hear them on here in a couple weeks um
we that's on case that's on you know
spotify itunes all that uh mostly we're
doing youtube these days trying to make
that switch over to video so subscribe
to the uh casey radio youtube i'm on
instagram kfc barstool that's where i do
uh my
several times a week video series one
minute man just kind of
uh you know
it's been by far the biggest you know
let me throw you some love you are the
absolute best at incorporating your
[ __ ] ads into those goddamn that is
my yeah
i have one talent in this world and it
is getting your promo code out there you
got it like any sponsors out there you
want your promo code i'll get it out
there man that's my ten thousand hours
i've been talking for so long i will
slip that
plug in that thing uh so yeah that's uh
kfc barstool on all social media and kfc
radio is the podcast so check it out all
right um one thing i i've come to love
and appreciate about this show is not
something i really intended when i
started but you know comedy
even what we do is is a it's a
individual sport it's you know it's
tennis it's boxing it's not football
it's not we're all and what a what a you
know i'll see you maybe at a festival or
at in town for a minute and some drinks
and i'm getting the best of you yep you
know but what a i've come to appreciate
what a way to really get to know the
people i've i've been just you know if
you take away what we do co-workers with
all these years
and i'm like damn you you went through
that while we were doing that right you
know holy [ __ ] i didn't know that you
know dude that's that's been uh that's
what my job has been i i for for really
no not on purpose
i when i started out at barstool
i was just like
i'm gonna tell the people who i am and
what i am and what i do
um
and there are definitely times i wish i
didn't do that like you can't you can't
put the toothpaste back in the tube
once everyone knows who you are and
who your family is and who your kids are
and all that [ __ ] you know they they
they want it all the time and i'm like
[ __ ] you know there's a lot of people in
my company and and barcelona and this
business would keep you know some some
things private and i didn't do that
because i was like i'm just gonna be
real you know and i knew like i started
out as an accountant i never had the
idea to be yeah anything right i know
you beyond yeah what i see online so
talk to me about the quick version
i uh i'm a new york guy through and
through born in the bronx lived outside
of philly for a little bit but other
than that my whole life in in new york
went to fordham for school yeah brother
sisters older brother younger sister
okay um
so middle child bronx kid went to school
got my mba together yes okay hate each
other's guts in front of you but yeah oh
yeah but but you know still love each
other and together to this day oh they
are yeah in a in a in an apartment that
is probably the size of this [ __ ]
studio
i told a story about my dad the other
day
uh when i bring my kids to their house
we sleep over my dad my dad goes to bed
at like seven o'clock to get the [ __ ]
away from my mom he wakes up at like
three then and he i just caught him he
was just sitting in in a room like this
size in the apartment just sitting just
waiting for like everyone else to wake
up just like just like nothing maybe
looking at his phone every now and then
but just like i was like that that's it
right there you know um so yeah so now i
get it right so um
uh fordham get my mba gonna go do this
finance thing all my friends are doing
finance trying to make some money in new
york i end up being an accountant at
deloitte uh right as the recession hit
like i graduate no 708 when the housing
market and everything collapses
everything that the the reason why the
economy collapsed is like the work that
i'm doing so i fall like ass backwards
into this job and then like the next day
i'm on cnbc they're like collateralized
debt obligations are like the cause of
and i was like oh [ __ ]
i just spent four years
so somehow make it through a couple
rounds of [ __ ] layoffs
dude it was brutal i was like
i'm like looking at these these
investments that are like the root of
all evil for our country and i'm [ __ ]
them up and i'm realizing why this is
happening i'm like yeah this is all
crazy yeah i was like
through school are you watching this and
learning this you know wait this shit's
not really adding up
barely like i am by no means like some
financial you know i don't know what's
going on but anybody could have looked
at this and been like
this money is you know supposed to be
going here here and here and it's only
going here because of this i'm a solid c
math student my whole career
all right i got a 3.0 every year for two
reasons after 16 my dad's dead so i'm on
my own drivers our insurance everything
and if you got a 3.0 state farm gave you
a discount good student discount
and i was a b student all right but i
would get c's in math and the only s the
only thing that canceled a c out was an
a so i made sure my ass was in
several gym classes to cancel these
[ __ ] seats you know what i mean
i was like i'll do all the push-ups
that was my so then boom i would get a
3.0 and i would get my discount on uh my
state
by the way i mean your whole upbringing
is or lack thereof to be honest yeah
doing it yourself with your brother it
is
and the way the stories like the humor
you find in it is [ __ ] so admirable
man some of the tales that are not funny
but so so [ __ ] funny if that's the
name of the game that's why that's why
this show means so much to me when i
watch it but as a as a shitty math
student i
knew right that something's wrong i was
like yeah i had a buddies like if you
have ten thousand dollars cash right now
i'm like that just doesn't sound right
like everyone's got a house
what
and and i remember one time so we would
do this you know a lot of accountants go
to a site and and i didn't do that i sat
at the same desk every day it was truly
like office space put a bullet in your
head yeah and i we would when we
finished the work it was it was old
schools and manila envelopes written
[ __ ] out you know and
i would like give that to somebody right
and one day i walked into a [ __ ]
closet like a like a office door that
usually is locked
and it was just all of the files
and i was like
what do we do it was like they were just
blasting them off into nothing you know
what it means like we finished the work
and they just like stabbed it away
you know and i was like what is going on
here and then when i ended up so
so that i'm doing that and like i said
i'm bad at it i'm miserable at it and
right and i'm reading bar stool as a way
to just pass the time and right as
that's happening
uh oh so i'm reading barstool i'm
miserable i start my own website for fun
just as like a creative outlet because
i'm so miserable at work and it's very
similar to barcelona it's a little bit
more like nostalgia what we did as an
80s baby and a 90s kid but a lot of the
same humor as barcelona right as i'm
doing that dave puts up a post on his
site saying i'm looking to expand into
new cities and i want a new york writer
first so i i emailed him i sent him my
site i was like nah man i got a good job
it pays well benefits all that [ __ ] i am
good man and my friends were like i
don't know at this point friends of
friends of friends have started three in
my website so it's still small but i'm
getting people reaching out to me being
like this is pretty funny man and like i
know you through this guy and so i'm
getting a little bit of confidence i
send it to dave and he's like i've
actually already seen this somebody sent
this to me nice so i was like oh [ __ ] so
he narrows it down to me and one other
guy
and at this point barstool is not what
it is today it's a risk you know and i'm
like i got this money and this good job
and he comes back and he says i can't
decide between you two how about you
split the job split the writing and you
can split the money and keep your old
job and i'm like oh perfect so now i can
do both i'm making a little extra money
and for two years i did both jobs nobody
at my accounting firm knew that i was a
blogger none of the blog readers knew
that i was an accountant so i was kind
of doing this double life thing
eventually bar still grows big enough i
grow
uh to the point that i'm getting fired
they were like they're like why don't we
talk about transferring you to another
department because you know things are
not working out and i was like i'm good
man i'm good i'm trying to get fired
because i want a severance package i
want to keep my cobra benefits and
they're not getting
they're not getting it bro
yeah i need that cobra
dude i've had a bunch of surgeries and
[ __ ] i needed
it's like half price man you know it
really is but i mean i've had i i've had
three shoulder surgeries two back
surgeries and neck surgery i can't not
having [ __ ] i'm not one of those guys
and i asked dave about insurance and
he's like yeah okay bud yeah for sure
thing
sure yeah
it's called be careful you know so uh i
eventually uh like get fired do bar
stool full time and that's when we
started new york
uh and then from there it was dominoes
we started philly we started chicago we
started college one
grows big enough we get some investment
everybody moves to new york
and everything you know just continues
to blow up from there but uh it was 2012
was when i started the podcast because
we it was all writing in the beginning
just blogging congratulations at heart
at my heart i'm a writer like i think
today is to this day i'm very
self-deprecating rarely talk about
myself in a good way i'm always just
clowning myself but i think to this day
at my prime in the in like the best
years of of the blog i don't think
there's anybody who could touch me
blogging like we were churning them out
like every 30 minutes
topics headlines pictures quick jokes
paragraphs of writing personal stuff
topics current event all of it man and
we were just churning out as much
writing as possible and i mean all of us
it was like everybody had their fastball
man it was it was like baseball in the
steroid era just everybody hitting bombs
you know but i was like this guy you
know i gotta i also at the same time
recognize that like they're they're
there are funnier people than me like
all these people now in the game now oh
my comics who are trained and and and
practice and you know and i'm just like
a dude who i'm just a straight shooter
like i'm just talking about my life what
works for me is that i just kind of tell
like it is and there's a lot of people
out there who go i agree you know and
i'm lucky that that's the case but it's
not technically i don't think i'm
talented you know what i mean i think i
just kind of tell it like it is and
hopefully there's a lot of people out
there who agree with me so i was like i
got to keep ahead of you know whatever's
next so that's why we started the
podcast so you know we were right about
that one placed a good bet early and so
we've got you know 10 years of the
podcast under our belt yeah trying to do
the same thing on instagram now and keep
up with the videos it was like
you know people knew me as a writer
we started to do the podcast and some
people liked it but a lot of people were
like oh i like you better as a writer i
don't like your voice i don't like your
style whatever then you do video people
like i don't like your face you got a
punchable face i don't i hate you yeah
so every time you do a new medium you
kind of you know you go out on a limb
and you risk yourself so
um you know but i was like i gotta keep
it moving or you just get eaten up you
know what i mean you get eaten alive
with whoever's coming right behind you
with all the new [ __ ] new apps new new
mediums all that stuff so
yeah i mean i i quickly you know
kind of fell in love and then almost
became like obsessed and addicted with
the content game it was just it's been
24 7 for [ __ ] 15 years yeah since
2009 just
never really content has to happen now
it is
it is you should be able to release a
special every three years and deep and
george carlin's level you know those
guys were doing that right right now
it's every [ __ ] day it's crazy it's
every day and it's interesting to me
because also i don't know that if i saw
something from carlin or pryor some
every eddie murphy everybody misses man
yeah i don't know that i would like
every goddamn thing no man it's it's
almost like comparing uh you know old
nba to new nba where it's like you know
some of these guys would get eaten for
lunch with some of the talent out there
because even when we used to blog i
would find a story in the news and i'd
be like i'm gonna take my time with that
one i'll publish that on like friday now
it's like you better get that up in the
next 15 minutes because someone else is
gonna have you know written that or
talked about it already algorithm
already pushed your [ __ ] down like
there's that there's that absolutely man
it's and it's
i mean i on one hand i love it on the
other hand it's like get me out of this
you know it's like
it's funny i did it to get out of the
rat race and i just entered another rat
race you know right and one that's much
more public and much more you know much
harsher and people
haters and criticizing and you know
judging and all that [ __ ] so
it's part it's what i love but it's also
sometimes i'm like i want a good will
hunting this [ __ ] and just disappear man
i did it one day i'm just gone well one
of the things i that that you and i had
communicated about before that you also
love is being a dad and i love that yeah
man um but you're a single dad as well
single dad divorced dad two kids talk to
me about that yeah so how old were you
when how old are your kids uh six and uh
just turned five so you're 31 when you
had your kids okay just about that um
and six and five so pretty quick pretty
quick well she's like she's starting set
yeah
almost irish twins type [ __ ] um which
was a surprise like uh oh really i uh
we i got married when i was like 30.
we had some reason to believe that maybe
we were gonna be able to have kids which
turned out to be
very untrue because uh we got married in
october
and
it was like i mean at this point i had
already started i was putting some money
away for adoption and ivf and stuff
because i thought that was the road
we're gonna eventually have to go down
i'm thinking to myself all right we're
gonna try for a while i'm gonna get it
in for a little bit have some fun if it
happens it happens if it doesn't you
know we're preparing
one and done really for baby number one
good for you dude
one and done for no whatever
damn just
hitting walk offs bro i mean it was like
and and when and when you are not
expecting that when you're thinking all
right i'm 30 31 now i'll be we'll be
trying for a couple years maybe have
some kids when i'm 35 and then all of a
sudden it's like no you're having one
right now and then it was like well
let's get the let's just do it all at
once and get the bad years out of the
way and it's one and done again i was
like oh
we just went into hyperdrive man we just
you know we just took the next what my
10-year plan was gonna be we're not
doing in [ __ ] 18 months so that was a
trip but they're unbelievable they are
you know they are uh i tried i started a
podcast called podfathers as well
i don't do it any longer um but
i i wanted to be like i'm gonna be the
honest parent on the internet because
there isn't one there's not one [ __ ]
honest person in this world when it
comes to that [ __ ] and i read all the
books when they when we were getting
ready and there's ones that are like
dude you're gonna be a parent like like
how to be a dad by a dad and i read it
and i was like this is so [ __ ] phony
you know so i started the podcast being
like
this is scary this is hard this it sucks
it's it's rewarding but it's not fun and
all that so i try to keep it very real
about talking about the kids
on the internet because it's like i i
hate how much people are like no no this
is my perfect life and my perfect kids
and everything's fine and you know
behind the [ __ ] closed doors
right right we're all doing our version
of sportscenter out there on social
media
and the thing i used to love at the
baseball games and i'd go with my dad
and [ __ ] was the bloopers yep i loved
watching those guys that you looked up
to like that guy never makes a mistake
and all of a sudden this one's bouncing
off his [ __ ] face and [ __ ] you know
that's why i think people like
podcasting too because you hear
some you know you don't hear the
polished jokes and the rehearsed lines
and all that you get to see what they're
really like
athletic greens is the health and
wellness company that makes
comprehensive daily nutrition really
simple with so many stressors in life
it's difficult to maintain effective
nutritional habits
and give our bodies the nutrients it
needs to thrive you know i talk about it
all the time whether it's parenting
touring just working traveling it's hard
to eat healthy and i start every day now
with ag-1 and i take my packets on the
road with me make sure i have my
ag-1 everywhere with me as the research
changes so does ag-1 while most
nutritional products that come to market
never evolve athletic greens continues
to obsessively improve ag-1 based on the
latest research producing 53
improvements over the last decade and
counting they invest in high quality and
reputable sources of each ingredient and
go above and beyond and third-party
testing to ensure their customers
continue to receive the highest quality
and best daily nutritional habits on the
planet it is lifestyle friendly so
whether you're eating keto paleo vegan
dairy free or gluten-free they got you
covered and it contains less than one
gram of added sugar no gmos no nasty
chemicals or artificial anything while
keeping it tasting good to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free one year supply
of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com
honeydew today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew to take
control of your health and give a.g one
a try lately i've been listening to a
lot of ymh and two bears one cave and
it's been great one reason it's been
great to listen to is because i use my
raycon wireless earbuds to do it
raycon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever with optimized
gel tips for the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds are so comfortable and i'm
telling you they will not budge
trust me raycons give you eight hours of
playtime and a 32-hour battery life
raycons are priced just right you get
quality audio at half the price of other
premium audio brands it's no wonder
raycon's everyday earbuds have over 50
000 five-star reviews the noise
isolation is perfect on the plane while
i travel at night pants nation tour
y'all and the earbud tap functions make
it easy to switch songs without pulling
my phone out let me say this i have
personal friends that hit me up like
look who's real yes they all have them
kirsten has them here she loves them go
to buy raycon.com
honeydew today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's by raycon dot com slash
honeydew to score 15 percent off buy
raycon.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
well i'll tell you i don't know
i don't know what the right thing to do
is or isn't but i'll tell you what i
just had to have a conversation with my
daughter and i was like
[ __ ] i'm gonna talk to her like she's
keep it real 15. yeah i'm gonna do it so
a friend of ours unfortunately his
daughter um died from a fentanyl a bad
you know hot shot
and he came to visit us in ocean city
when we were back i took her there and
um i asked him you know how are you
doing and you know we're talking i'm not
hiding in front of my daughter she can
see his sadness and he's like i'm good
you know and so later she's like what
happened
and i was like his daughter passed away
and she's like how and i'm like
and i'm like all right you know i do
again i'm not good at math but i do
quick math she's seven i've had people
come on here talking about doing drugs
eleven twelve and this fentanyl shits
yeah everywhere and i so i told her i
told her exactly what holy moly what
this poison was yeah and that even
though she wasn't a bad person sometimes
good people make bad choices
and those choices how'd that go can and
she was like and so then i led it into
me smoking marijuana i told you really i
told her i said i said so then we
started talking about everything yeah we
talked about fentanyl and this poison
and she she's 12 years old
wow she also has um
our neighbors smoke cigarettes and
she'll ask me about cigarettes
and then she'll ask me about um you know
she sees the billboards cannabis all
that um so
i was like we were driving from ocean
city to philly and i was like we got two
hours yeah let's do it we're gonna have
there's ever a time conversation because
god forbid right some kid in two years
from now gets a pill from their older
brother and it's a [ __ ] dirty perk or
whatever and then my kid takes it and
kills her and i didn't never you know i
also panic about that like um i had kim
congdon on on the podcast and she said
you know up until a couple years ago
i was taking a [ __ ] bagel out of a
toaster with a fork and she's like
someone never my parents never told you
and then you start worrying about what
did i not talk about
nowhere near water we're over you know
we've covered that so i'm like you know
what [ __ ] i'm gonna tell you isn't
that i mean there's just so much and i
tell her that marijuana if is medicine
it's my doctor's the one who prescribed
it to me which is all true he knows what
i do i go get chest x-rays right but
don't ever smoke tobacco right don't you
know what i mean i'm trying to tell her
because god forbid something happens to
me and my kids over there [ __ ]
smoking pcps right you know so you get
to philly she's rolling the blunt
she's just breaking it up
licking it
twisting it up put that filter on it
girl
that doesn't smoke backwards come on
we're doing those pre-rolls come on girl
i i don't know
i don't know if fentanyl at seven's
right but i don't know if it's wrong
either so i was like god forbid
i can say with certainty
maybe there was a playbook back i don't
think there was ever a real playbook but
maybe back in the day when [ __ ] was
cookie cutter and pleasantville white
picket fences and americana and all that
[ __ ] with the internet and how fast the
world moves and how [ __ ] everybody
knows everything now like
you know i don't think parents were
teaching those lessons because they
didn't know because you know also back
then no one knew a kid that died from
fentanyl right right and you know what i
said new [ __ ] and if somebody if a kid
did die from that the parents told the
story and kept it quiet and because
there's no social media and no gossip
you just you didn't know so the parents
don't even know the stories yeah now
we're gonna we know about sex
trafficking and drug trafficking and you
know epstein this and yeah you know it's
like
so who the [ __ ] is prepared to tell any
of these
you know i don't even like
i'm sure you know they're more qualified
people but are they really it's like to
these these doctors gone through all
this [ __ ] too because now now everybody
experiences everything in the world and
there's a lot of [ __ ] up stuff there's
a lot and i go back and forth between
like
i i think it's admirable to talk that
young but i'm also like or is the job
keep them in that bubble as long as you
can because there's plenty of life to
worry about all this [ __ ] but yeah the
questions are rolling in man and it's
like i'll tell you i would i wanted to
do that yeah but that fentanyl [ __ ]
scared our personal bubble you know what
i mean it's a really good friend of mine
sitting there with his daughter you know
talking about his daughter and one of
those you know everything's gonna happen
to you
it can happen to absolutely anybody so
then your kid's asking you what happened
then i'm like oh you know she knows she
died dude you know what drives me nuts
so my daughter shea is in kindergarten
this year
and it's around easter time she's in
catholic school and she comes home and
she goes
why did they nail jesus to a cross i'm
talking about that and i'm way worse i'm
like
i'm sitting here i'm like
she's six that's why can we just talk
about like do unto others as you do to
them we just hit the commandments all
right
how about the ten of those first and so
i go to her i go
and she's very smart man i know everyone
says their kids are smart but she's
she's she's annoyingly smart we're like
you can't even get [ __ ] past her anymore
she texts she texts me at six now she's
you know so i say to her i was like that
was that was you know what that was just
the joke he was just hanging on that
that they didn't do that for real and
she goes okay
she kind of looks around and she goes
back she goes
but they told me he they nailed him to
the cross and i was like
what do we need to do this at six
you motherfu cross and went through both
of them and then did you know he died
from asphyxiation actually did you know
that's the real way you die from
crucifixion daddy like [ __ ] can
we please just not do this yet
that drove me nuts you know what else
drove me nuts i did a couple things one
of the main things i want to tell people
to be ready for when you have kids at
least if you know you're living in the
suburbs and you've got you got some
means and some money
i got hit with the tuition word
when they were two years old yeah i did
not know that you pay tuition i thought
tuition was college maybe boarding
school or private school right yeah like
they were two years old
going to school two days for two hours
the two's program glorifying themselves
and then you do the threes and then you
do the fours and then you do pre-k
there's four years before [ __ ]
kindergarten now
i don't know 15 000
last year for [ __ ] glorified
babysitting and i did not know that man
i was like whoa whoa i factored in a lot
of costs i did not factor in i don't
remember going to we did anything but
right into kindergarten i think maybe
i was going to say maybe there was a
half day sort of pre-k
you know i'll do whatever for my kids
they're reading and writing like
probably way before we did and all that
they are but also it's like
tuition yeah ten thousand dollars for
this [ __ ] you know and and they also
come home asking me about crucifixions
yeah you should pay me yeah right i'm
not teaching on this [ __ ] you know
what's the 222 without the christ plan
in it huh y'all got that
keep the jesus out of it player is there
a bronze package
can i get
the entry level please
[ __ ] man it was brutal um
but they are like everything for me
can i ask you about because i know
splitting with uh and wanting to just
knowing
here's what's the truth more than not
being with my daughter's mother like not
being able to have my daughter every day
it almost killed me for real it is it's
physical i mean i'll probably start
crying
i wasn't gonna cry
i said not the first time i'll cry on
the second time i'm not i'll do i'll do
it jeremiah i'll cry on the second card
he cried on all was it
yeah kidney stones i had i had blood
clots i mean
massive health at 42 when that happened
and i know it was a direct uh result of
the stress and the anxiety i mean i
would put myself through mental torture
like oh my god every every night
person's gonna come over there right now
every night a long time i mean you know
i'm going on
five years four or five years now man
yeah of of being split and like and we
split when they were early because it
old uh
she was two and keegan was
uh just born really um
seven months so like uh you know things
as i was describing you know we the kids
were a bit of a surprise bar stool was
taken off in a way that i don't think
either of us ever expected it to
uh probably just had some issues you
know that we should have been addressing
rather than i mean i'm irish catholic
she's irish catholic i think a lot of us
was just pushing all your feelings and
emotions down and didn't address some
things
uh i [ __ ] up uh she finds out it goes
public it's a whole [ __ ] to-do it's i
mean a level that i never even
could begin to imagine daily mail new
york post page six people magazine
people like p p paparazzi outside the
office
people it's like ryan reynolds and blake
lively and they're like you know i'm
like jesus [ __ ] christ i can't it was
kind of right when the me too [ __ ] was
going on so i think it was like
salacious and and and here's the thing
man doesn't trip you out for a second
though like all the divorces in the
world like why what the [ __ ] is mine
well i think like bar stool is this
lightning rod in the media you know and
the me too [ __ ] was popping and
um and i am very public with my life and
part of the times i was happy and i'm
posting about my kids and there are
happy moments and it's the highlights
i'm not posting in the low lights you
know so people are surprised they think
i'm a liar i gotta go through that um
what we do is i'm busting balls a lot
i'm making fun of a lot of people you
know what i have learned in this game is
like i i'll i'll clown on you but i'm
not actually judging you because now
i've learned you know i talked a lot of
[ __ ] about people who who cheated and
got caught and this and that and now i'm
like well i never realized you know how
these situations unfold and now i
learned like you know like shut the [ __ ]
up young man you don't know what you're
talking about yet you know so uh so that
that all goes down and uh and i never
because i never wanted to do any of this
[ __ ] like i'm solo dolo man i don't have
an agent i don't have a manager i don't
have representation pr none of that so
this goes down and it's way bigger than
i ever expected
i go to dave and my boss erica and i'm
like what do we you know what do i do
here
i remember they they got me a meeting
with like a big pr firm because i was
like what do i do
and they recommended that me
and my now ex-wife put out a joint
statement together
same written statement posted on your
instagrams blah blah blah blah blah and
i'm like again i'm not [ __ ] brad and
angelina
i'm just the dude from the internet like
i'm an internet nerd man we don't do
this
p.s she ain't writing the same [ __ ] as
me and posting you know yeah right we
are not celebrities that have [ __ ] to to
to like salvage she went scored started
she didn't give a [ __ ] you know what i
mean so like that wasn't gonna work so i
realized i was on my own to go through
that so i'm dealing with that and and i
kind of realized once
the level that it blew up at work with
my fans and my my haters and the people
who like me and don't like me and how
much [ __ ] i mean to this day every
single day is a beating on the internet
for me i say anything and it's like oh
weren't you that guy that did that thing
you know so i'm still dealing with like
the pr of all that and i knew i was like
you know if we were gonna salvage it
there's gonna have to be a lot of
apologizing and and uh
changes and and you know
taking blame and fault and all that [ __ ]
and i was like this is it's not gonna
you know with everything that's blowing
up it's not gonna happen so i'm dealing
with that while and i also said the last
thing i want to do is try and string it
along and we end up getting divorced
when they are 11 and nine and that's the
worst [ __ ] time in the world to do it
so let's just do it now and
unfortunately it's all the way the
relationship they're going to watch in
front of them for that next nine eleven
years is not gonna be a healthy i go
back and forth you think so i'm like i
go back and forth between
you know yeah of course if you're like
in a truly abusive relationship of
course you know nobody wants to see that
but if we were going to be like adults
and and just kind of keep it behind
closed doors and mommy and daddy put on
a front and you get to see both of them
all the time
i every every day of my life probably
until i'm dead i will i will juggle that
in my head like should i have done that
but i know if we went through a divorce
at a later age it would have been brutal
so i say this i and i struggle with that
too but i do feel like
the 100 percent of me that my daughter
gets 50 of the time
is a better version of the 100 of me she
would have got a hundred percent of the
time yeah in that relationship not if
that i wholeheartedly
and i beat myself up to death man like i
if i don't see them i i get them on
thursdays we we do a little different i
don't do that wednesday and every other
[ __ ] because that's a long [ __ ] time
you know and god bless you if you do
you're 50 though right yeah 50 but i
have them on thursday nights and
saturday nights and then monday tuesday
wednesday i'll like pop over and take
them to school or whatever so i'm seeing
them like every other day it's it's even
that drives me crazy you know right now
we're in la i got a wedding this weekend
and i'm i'm going to see them like once
this week and i'm like [ __ ] mugging
because i'm trying to facetime and
everything thank god
for real i mean you know like i don't
know what it would be like back in the
day you truly you divorced and you like
lose your kids you know you're like i'll
go start another one
let me see if i can pick this phone up
here and call somebody who's got another
one of these hanging on their wall and
hopefully somebody's in the house to
pick it up and talk to me right and
they'll have an hour to you know just
sit there and talk
yeah i mean thank god technology is the
devil but it's made some things better
too right
so it's made being a single parent uh
infinitely yeah it's been better she
pops on the text and we have this little
thing now if uh if i see a purple heart
come through from her mom's number i
know that it's her and i said you know
we have these little
little things and you know the questions
are starting i am
dreading the day that they can read you
know the internet and and
you know read what happened and have
questions about why that happened i have
no idea i'll be like can we talk about
fentanyl instead
i'm gonna talk to ryan about that don't
worry about it don't worry about mom and
dad let me tell you about overdosing on
the fentanyl that's an easier
conversation for daddy to have right now
all right so talk to me about how um
you're actually splitting where do you
how far do you move right next door man
so like we lived in the same house for
like another eight months trying to sell
it of course at the worst time in the
market i'm convinced that i'm on the
truman show sometimes bad [ __ ] just
keeps happening to me and it's little
things like it's a heat wave in new york
and her air conditioner broke and i had
to fix the air conditioner and if it
wasn't that it was the heater and the
winter and if it's not that there's
hornets in the backyard and she's always
like what the [ __ ] and what i'm learning
i i you know maybe it's that main
character syndrome where i'm like
everything's always happening to me and
when i realize it's just like everybody
it's always happening to everybody life
[ __ ] stinks and everyone's dealing
with some [ __ ] but it really does feel
like overdrive for me anytime i go away
that's when something happens and i need
to be home and i'm getting [ __ ] for not
being you know it's all of that so uh we
we lived in the same house for a little
while sell the house at you know losing
taking a bath on it uh and then i just
moved one town next door
um they got an apartment i got an
apartment now that i got them set up in
a house so they're in like a
in the you know nice neighborhood for a
house they can be in for years and years
and i'm right next door so um great yeah
i can just kind of pop over and
work in progress you know it's it's
always uh
i'll be i'll be as you know
cordial and cool and as happy as
she wants to be and what were your
biggest fears being
away from your kids every day
uh
i guess it's like
i i feel a very you know that irish
catholic guilt type [ __ ] where it's like
i was what i should be doing you know i
and a lot of my friends none of my
friends are really divorced like is that
kind of the only one as much as as much
as it's 50 of everyone's getting
divorced it's like you know that's
factoring in a lot of people from a lot
of different economic backgrounds and
different places in the country my crew
my neighborhoods my people
they either are happy or they stick it
out you know and so i was kind of alone
on that front um
and and and so it was embarrassing you
know i mean the the the tabloid [ __ ] was
mortifying and to this day i still want
to [ __ ] kill every you know every
troll on the internet i'm just like
you know and i could say my piece but
i'm never gonna and you know there's
there's so many layers to that but that
feeling of like this you know you're not
doing your job now you're not there
and and still to this day when there's a
problem that i feel like i should be
helping with or a milestone that i'm
missing but then i go back and then i'm
like
i also know people who are happily
married who see their kids less than
than i do lawyers and doctors and people
who travel who just live a lifestyle
where they're like i'm okay seeing my
kids once every you know a couple weeks
or whatever yeah and i'm like yeah
it's their own full tour around the
weekend
absolutely you know i mean i i i it
sucks i feel bad for my team because
you know we could probably be bigger and
better and and more lucrative than we
are but i'm like
you know no thursday nights like i'm
trying to i'll do it one weekend a month
like i'll go away yeah childhood right
like i'm not i'm not you know we could
be on tour bouncing all across the world
but i'm just like i'm not doing it man
and it's not even it's it's it's like
selfish but it's also like i will not be
good at this job if i am sitting here
like i want to because i don't want to
kill someone you know so a lot of it was
guilt i never really thought like i knew
they're in good hands their mom is
amazing uh we have grandparents around
and and i'm an amazing nanny fell from
the [ __ ] clouds
mary off the boat irish you know been
manning your own boys
yeah so like
being raised by this you know woman with
this amazing brogue like she's part of
our family um
so like i wasn't like
they need me but they need me you know
and and i want to be there and where's
that come from where's the the want to
be a good dad come from is your
yeah
i'm actually my mom is is like the one
you know my personality takes after
i i realized later in life that's where
my humor comes from she's a die-hard
mets fan and she poisoned me with that
life and so i'm always watching games
with her and yelling and we're talking
[ __ ] and all that stuff so that's i'm
probably you know she's she's we're very
matriarchal family you know she kind of
runs the show and my dad is just uh like
he's just
he's just a chill dude who has just
always like paid the bills did the work
what's the work what did he do uh he he
did property management in new york city
so he came from like the sticks of
pennsylvania uh out by like erie
pennsylvania mead bill he called him
pennsyltucky and uh he just you know
rolled to new york i think solo ended up
going to the merchant marines and then
he started running uh
uh property in new york to the point
that he was the he ran the empire state
building for a while and that was like
the
yeah he was the chief operating officer
of the
uh empire state board did you get to go
up in all time dude
extra level like oh yeah everywhere we
can go and then you can go
yeah you can go the next one where
you're like okay cool let's get that
my brother proposed up there he got did
he really yeah that's cool yeah he set
that up that was cool that was like the
you know the big moment for he he he was
uh he worked for the durst family you
know the the jinx on hbo fritz the yeah
but yeah
that's right yeah so he was working for
them before any of that came out and i
remember him coming home and being like
my boss's brother is like you guys would
be this guy's crazy and we were like all
right cool whatever him that was robert
yeah
that series came out he was like i saw
all of that man chill out all summer
long with dad grass because it's too
nice out to be couch locked they'll
mellow you out while keeping your head
clear and ease away the stress of the
day that grass is legal organic hemp
that relaxes your body and mellows your
mind that grass cbd products are made
with 100 organic hemp that's easy to
dose and the effects come on smooth they
offer a variety of products from their
token smokable pre-roll joints which are
my favorite as well as hemp flour and a
variety of cbd tincture drops enjoy the
effects of cbd while keeping a clear
head all daggrass products are federally
legal for ages 18 and over and it ships
right to your door anywhere in the u.s
i'm going to say this too i just had a
really funny comedian avery pearson uh
at the comedy store uh the other night
and he's like man that weed that
everybody smokes these days is two
it's too heavy i'm looking for the
opposite i'm looking i said
glad you said something avery go to
daggrass.com had them look it up right
there even showed them the mom grass
y'all it's good stuff i promise so
go to
dadgrass.com honeydew to check out all
their products whether you're looking
for a new buzz or a chill way to enjoy
an old favorite dagress will leave you
in a euphoric mood right now dadgrass is
offering our listeners 20 off your first
order when you go to dadgrass.com
honeydew go to
dadgrass.com honeydew for 20 off your
first order that's dadgrass.com
honeydew this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp life can be overwhelming and
many people are burned out without even
knowing it symptoms can include lack of
motivation feeling helpless or trapped
attachment fatigue and more i know when
i'm burned out man i want to stay in bed
i want to nap if i can i don't want to
do anything i don't really want to go
anywhere i procrastinate and we
associate burnout with work but that's
not the only cause any of our roles in
life can lead us to feel burned out and
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
you know i'm a big believer in therapy
you know take that plunge get out there
start talking to somebody get this stuff
out it's worked you know it's work but
it's worth it i promise you better help
is customized online therapy that offers
videophone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours
honeydew listeners get 10 off the first
month at betterhelp.com honeydew that's
better h-e-l-p-com
honeydew for 10 off your first month now
let's get back to the duke wasn't he the
one that got pinched right here in santa
monica by uh delivery like he [ __ ] up
somehow someone recognized him yeah yeah
yeah because he uh he was wearing he had
multiple uh personal uh
aliases and all that yeah he stole a
candy bar or something like that it was
like
petty theft
and that like unraveled it all and then
they did the documentary with him and he
accidentally
admitted it like on the air oh is that
the one where he's on there because i
can't i did it i killed them all what
are you yeah when he's taking a piss or
something forgot his mic was on yeah wow
crazy although
i i don't even like to tell people this
but i did read that that was a little
bit of like movie magic like he said
that but not the timeline wasn't exactly
the same i see but they did catch him
like those documentary
those documentarians like caught him
with that [ __ ] it's wild but he so he
worked for them and then the empire
state building he had highs and lows in
his career so i kind of learned like you
know never rest on your laurels and you
know keep working
my brother was following in line doing
that [ __ ] and i was probably gonna you
know have something to do in that realm
and i felt like i remember i kind of
like
not that it was the family business but
when i went to do this stuff i remember
thinking like oh i don't know if my dad
would be upset or whatever my brother
ends up coming to work for me
oh yeah so he he was the one who got me
into the podcast he was he's uh a tech
nerd he's always like you got to be on
this other side yeah like he he was the
producer side of my my show he's the one
who makes one minute man every day he's
the one who started the podcast with me
he's like he was telling me to be on tik
tok when it was musically and all that
[ __ ] so he's always like next what's up
whatever's next but i remember him he he
you know my dad had got on some jobs and
some some legs up in that industry and
when my brother went to to tell him that
he was quitting to come to do my [ __ ]
full-time
he was like nervous about it and my dad
was like
are you [ __ ] kidding me like go run
man you know that sounds awesome like so
always had very very supportive parents
and and through the through the divorce
and and all that as well like i remember
thinking i was like such an
embarrassment and you know a disgrace
and
you know why why do you feel that well
again because like no one in our family
got divorced certainly nobody had any
cheating scandals nobody's ever been on
you know i'm sure
they'd never told me about it but i'm
sure family members were calling and
being like you know what's the dirt and
all that [ __ ] so i'm sure it was not fun
for anybody in my family to go through
that but they never wavered like they
were always like we got your back just
it's just about the kids like you know
so family life has always been
as normal you know but as solid as can
be to let me go through married as well
she just got married yup um so she's 29
my brother's
four years older than me so
right in the middle of that
um and do they have any kids yet or my
brother has kids she's she just got
married so she's that's next for her
so everybody's doing it the old
traditional way
right she just got married i'm like oh
sorry i forgot you got to be married to
him kids
and your family yes
you're an irish catholic we're italian
catalina nobody else
[Laughter]
yeah i mean it's been uh it's been weird
though like the the whole barcelo
journey of kind of being like in the
public eye and and doing you know
especially when nobody was
expecting it so all of a sudden i
remember telling my parents like i'm
going to quit my job to go to this blog
and they were kind of cool they were
pretty cool most i feel like most people
have a story where their parents like
don't you do it you know and they were
like does it pay good enough okay
and then like started i told them i was
like don't ever listen i don't want you
guys ever listening i told them i read
for a sports blog and back when it
started it was like we're doing local
smoke show of the day
like i was like your son is a full-blown
smut peddler at this point and i
remember telling my mom don't ever
listen don't ever watch and thankfully
she is so technologically inept that she
couldn't if she wanted to but i remember
at like a family event my dad
we were at like the buffet or getting a
drink whatever he leans over and he goes
this is not a sports blog
and i was like no it is not bro
but um i mean it's you know gonna make
me hopefully more money than i ever
imagined and i that's
the i think the the biggest takeaway i
have in life now is
you you can't do everything 100 you know
and i think life is entirely about
juggling like
especially for i know you know women and
have certainly have their own struggle
but i feel like for guys you got to be a
new age dude
who's in plugged in with their emotions
and society and all that but at the same
time you still got to be the old school
like
wait take care of everything commercials
and go change the [ __ ] oil you want
me to do that
brother you just said it's so much
better
i'd rather cry at the commercial i am
weeping at the commercials bro and you
can fix the tire and change the oil
yourself you want me to do the brakes
right now i'm i'm over here crying on a
lifetime movie for crazy trying to get
in touch with my feelings have you seen
the kardashians right now i'm in the
middle of the last five languages of
love for christ's sake i don't have time
to go get a hornet's nest uh it's so
true man and uh but yeah that that that
first especially when you're doing
something you when you're doing
something you hate and you're just doing
for the bills
you know
my one of my first brands was being a
cubicle monkey and i could really
resonate with the people who were
sitting at their desk so a lot of my
blogs a lot of my podcasts were about
the little you know little nuances of
being stuck in a cube and people were
like that's exactly what it's like i
could really relate to that and so i
always my mantra was mail time do as
little as you can
but to make as much money as you can and
get promoted don't be the guy who comes
in early and stays late uh you know bare
minimum while snaking it snake until you
make it was always my you know mantra
but i you know when you when you have a
job you hate you're just like [ __ ] i
just got to do this when you when you
have a job that you either love or you
know the more that i put in the more i'm
going to get out i was kind of like you
know
i could be
i could be working right now and that
could mean big things for down the road
and but do i balance that with and i
think i i think i balanced a little too
hard with
home life i think like early on i was
trying to be i passed on work trips i
passed on opportunities starting new
shows i was like i already work a lot as
it is and i think you know i gotta focus
on my marriage and she's gonna be upset
if i do this that and the other thing
and i i started to resent that and you
know once i was single i was like i said
yes to everything my career [ __ ] took
off you know so it's it's it's a sad you
know real reality of life that's like
you know there's only 24 hours in a day
you know and so that that's you know
like i i could do this but i got to see
my kids and
and you know the kids are the one thing
i just don't ever waver on now that's
you know the first and foremost yeah
so we'll see i mean it's been a long
road next year is when we had uh penn
nationals a
uh casino conglomerate like gambling
conglomerate came in and bought us
so next year is when
all of my equity vests and i've been
waiting for that day for a long [ __ ]
time yeah bro and uh
not that you know money can make up for
certain things and buy happiness and all
that [ __ ] we all know that but it goes a
long way it can make if it can make
things feel like it was you know well it
was worth it or
no one's worrying about college no one's
gonna worry about houses no one's gonna
worry about you know anything
financially really oh yeah and i think
there's still some honor in that you
know so
that that'll that'll come in and make
things hopefully although i don't know
man like i said
if
mo money mo problems has been the
realest [ __ ] for me everything i was my
happiest and my
my most like carefree when i was making
you know
50k in new york city trying to just like
you know four guys in a three-bedroom
apartment yeah so we'll see but
god willing bro
so do you get along enough with your ex
that you guys can you're you're good in
front of the kids keep it professional
for say professional for sure yeah yeah
she's she's got a new boyfriend who's a
cool dude
he's been around for a while uh he when
it first happened how was that
um i was okay when it first happened
only you didn't have any anxiety about
it or
oh man no i mean i i was okay with it i
was like you know
it what happened happened what you know
where we're going is where we're going
and you got somebody like all good um
what what's been a little weird is as
the kids have gotten older
and you know sometimes
he's doing stuff with them or they're
talking about him and i'm like
like uh
it was my son's birthday recently and he
got him
uh mario odyssey on the nintendo
and so he runs to him every time he
can't beat a boss or finish a level and
so i [ __ ] went and bought mario and
played it on the plane out here
[Music]
so i'm on the phone oh yeah does he know
about this exact big ass yeah how about
that i've literally used the whole
screen
i played i played mario odyssey on the
plane for four straight [ __ ] hours
just so i could know every you know nook
and cranny of the game and i facetime
and i say keegan guess what i've been
doing i've been playing mario so you
know anything that you can't beat or
anything you can come to me now and he
goes i can i can beat all of it and just
runs away i was like [ __ ]
whatever just keep doing it because
you're going to be that one it's going
to be that one time he's like yeah
yeah there you go let me show you yeah
let me tell you something young buck
yeah mario i can do he's playing
minecraft yeah bro i'm out i was like go
talk
to the boyfriend yeah
all right that's the weird [ __ ] you're
gonna do that man
i'm always joking too i like i have
these [ __ ] up shoulders and back and
stuff so when it comes time to you know
how do i tackle and you know can we can
we throw the go go with him daddy's
watching tv when you want to talk about
podcasting in the internet you come talk
to me all right
yeah but yeah i mean there's a level of
it's not anxiety because he's a good
dude everything's fine but it's a uh
it's just a
you know an ego thing and like a little
like all right wait a minute you know
part of it's me too is that fomo that
yeah like i'm here i'm missing out on
this this moment with my kid that this
other person's getting experience and
man i'm well i want to have that moment
with my kid i remember like christmases
when he started coming around for that
and it was like you know putting up
ornaments and [ __ ] and i was like
that that was one of the uh when we were
married there was a breaking point where
things were not good and like
uh the
daughter was just first born so it
doesn't matter she was a newborn she
couldn't even tell but they i was ready
i was happy like excited to decorate the
tree and i came home and she had already
done it without me and was kind of like
oh i didn't even know you wanted to do
that and i was like yes you did you know
like stuff like that so christmas and
holiday like holidays just just this
year for the first time i've been okay
around holidays like holidays were
brutal oh yeah i mean
i'm [ __ ] crying at flag day you know
what i mean
i'm like oh it's pregnancy
[Laughter]
so that's just no fun but i'm finally in
a good spot now and like you know
as they get older part of me is like i
like that i can explain to them you know
a little more but it also comes with the
responsibility of explaining more things
so you know everything is everything is
a double episode our parents well not
yours but my parents divorced it wasn't
on the [ __ ] internet too that i could
tell you my narrative and you don't have
it's
not the story yeah yeah
let me tell you something brother let me
tell you there's a narrative out there
yeah i know there is one side to the
story that they will be reading and i
you know that'll probably be telling you
if it was 1995 or earlier it was my
story
you know
you know how [ __ ] great
divorce was for the
first 300 years of it yeah when you just
you just you just got up and moved to
the town next door and it was over now
everyone's connected and sees who you're
dating and every social media and we're
gonna text and we're gonna talk and it's
like
it took me exhausting the other thing
that gives me anxiety too is it took me
47 years to finally get
i'm 49 now but it took 47 to get my
personal life my
work and my daughter's mother's house
within a three mile radius wow so i'm
within 15 minutes
in the rain at rush hour yeah that's
when i tested it i was like let's see
what this is the freeway in the morning
and get there in nine minutes right you
know what i mean invaluable and even
though i'm still that close it feels
like there's this whole there she's on
another planet so they could be when
they tell them on the other side of the
wall and as long as you're not engaged
you know what i mean
what up what up lily rose princess cop
that girl
it's never close enough there's never no
that's also kind of what i think uh
gave me a little bit of solace is
uh or like i kind of let go a little bit
was like there's never gonna be enough
time like if
if we were still together and i was with
them 16 hours a day i would want 17. you
know what i mean and like and especially
as they they've started to do more like
now i'm freezing and i'm like hey i'm
gonna come over and they're like no we
gotta play date and we're gonna go to
camp and we're i'm like oh sorry all
right
i'm like good i'm like all right yeah
yeah fine like live your life i'm not
gonna be i'm gonna be that parent but
you know in the beginning when it's like
they just have their parents you want to
be the one that's there every [ __ ]
second you know yeah so the other day i
dropped my daughter off at camp and
everybody was already there and she's
like all right dad i was like all right
nothing she's like i go this it's
happening now you don't want to hug me
in front of your friends already yeah
yeah luckily you know they they do like
me still so i close out every live show
with uh the crowd
saying you know i saw that hi shane
and um
and and i did i've done it like three
four times already right it's like a new
thing we're doing i plan to do it
forever and one day i'm gonna have this
compilation of it you know and i uh
i showed it to her and she
i the first few she it was hi shane
keegan we love you and we miss you and
then this one she wanted the crowd to
say daddy is so silly and i forgot to do
that so i show it to her and she goes
they didn't say daddy sell me and i was
like you go play with the boyfriend
seriously that is one thing i will say
is like i i you know especially through
the pandemic
and i know some people were stuck in
some marriages and situations and homes
and stuff where like
having my freedom
to work and to get away and all that you
know there's no way i would have lasted
like a 40 years just kind of
just swallowing it and pushing it down
like
it's tough but i needed it it makes
sense to me my my father had so much
stress and anxiety now and a divorce in
the 80s like you're working he's driving
commute is an hour each way
and you don't know where your kids are
you know you can't talk about no
all day long hoping that when you come
home everything's fine all good yeah
brutal man
but but there's also like they weren't
thinking that way either right but maybe
they were you know internally there's
something going on but us it's like
we gotta text every second gotta know
every second and
you don't really need to you know but
because you can you have to it's like
and like i don't i learned early on i
don't do the oh to my daughter because
my daughter will tell him she'll tell me
everything she won't tell me right away
she's like i don't want to talk about
i'm like all right and then maybe 30
minutes later you're like hey dad yeah
yeah here we go
let her lay it out yeah yeah ask me what
[ __ ] is you know and so i i had to take
her um she's been with me to baltimore
on tour and she's been she did a uh with
a weekend with me in la jolla
and she's sitting in the green room with
kirsten and the dog dog was like real
small then
and um after a couple shows she goes the
next day she goes dad
why do you guys all say the same thing
over and over jesus christ you sound
like the internet chick i go we're
working on something here for god's sake
like she learned what stan like yeah
great first time like wait you're saying
the same [ __ ] again and again i heard
this one yeah i heard this one oh my god
what the [ __ ]
that's a joke you did it
she said to me the other day uh she's
she's a dancer and so she's done a
couple recitals and i can tell she's
already gonna have some anxiety she's a
nervous kid and she says like dad when
you go on stage are you nervous and i
was like every damn time i sweat through
my shirt every time i'm still new to it
i freak out
every time and i do it every time
because i know i want to and i know i'm
going to be proud at the end and she was
like yeah yeah yeah cause after you do
it you feel like a superhero and i was
like
i know right
these things that these kids say man uh
it was it was my son's birthday the
other day and we're after a party after
the party ends he passes out in the car
and i pick him up and he's sleeping on
my shoulder and he he just goes
dad i loved my birthday morning thank
you so much and i'm like and that was
that's what it's all about yeah yeah
those moments are like thank god for
those moments because the rest of that
[ __ ] sucks yeah you know
all right so um i told you at the end of
this i would ask you advice you would
give to your 16 year old self we're
there so yeah after
it's interesting because you had a a a
solid upbringing it sounds like yeah i
know you say your parents hated each
other but still together still working
it all out and then you're the you're
the divorce
yeah and the black sheep yeah i mean i i
once wrote a blog about this
advice from my unborn son
who i'll never meet because god's gonna
curse me with daughters that was the
title of the thing come to find out you
know nobody's cursed with daughters they
are like the the best blessing in the
world you know but i but it was a lot
more of like
you know i went to fordham where
after i graduated no need to go back no
sports no alma mater so it was things
like i want you to go to a big sports
program for college and you know funner
things you know that are
are uh
not as serious but i think i've come to
learn that
the
the uh fear that i had of rejection in
all things girls
work sports like whatever
i i
if i could if i could get rid of one if
i could do one thing i would have him
have him and her have no fear of
rejection like go
you know ask that girl out
go try to play that sport take the shot
don't pass the ball you know don't like
when i played sports i was thinking i
took charges and dove on the floor for
loose balls and i wouldn't i wasn't the
guy taking that you know i'm like shoot
please play selfish and you know be be
you know
put yourself out there and and like i i
think i've just finally got to a spot
after going through the [ __ ] fire on
the internet where i truly do not care
anymore not that i don't there's a lot
of people who say they don't care i
truly have gotten to a point where i
don't care within reason you know and
once that happens it's so freeing you
know yeah and it's it's so it's
impossible to get a young kid and then a
teenager and someone going through
adolescence to not care because you just
have to live through it and all that but
if i could get you know if i could get
them to realize that like most of these
people do not [ __ ] matter and only
like you and your family and what you do
and the close ones are what matter most
so like
you know
date around oh yeah i i actually do
think i don't think anybody should even
be close to having a serious
relationship until they're like 27. so
that's it that might be one of my rules
because it's like
when i see some young kids who are like
broken up or and and and
suicidal and and depressed and [ __ ] it's
like you guys are [ __ ] like 19 you
know what i mean so i mean i have some
little things like tangible specifics
but i think the broader thing of like
just especially on the internet and the
world they're going to live in where
you're connected to way too many people
and who knows what the [ __ ] else is
going to be out there in 10 years i
genuinely think we will look back on
social media
the same way we looked at cigarettes and
alcohol and stuff where it was like we
just everybody had it all the time and
it was [ __ ] ruining everybody and now
we have to control it and because your
brain is just not designed to have that
much stimulation from that many people
you know and so i i just hope to god
when they are
you know
getting
followers and [ __ ]
comments and dms and all that [ __ ] that
they just know
you know these people's opinions don't
matter whether it's the fear of
rejection or the feeling inferior or
feeling bad or whatever
like none of that matters it does just
do you man good for you and be normal
not enough normal kids out there be nice
be nice be normal like just be so it's
so it seems so easy but every room i
walk into i'm like oh these people are
so [ __ ] weird why you guys just be
normal just be nice simple as that man
well thank you for being here i
appreciate it man it was a great episode
like i said man you're one of the the
realest in the game so thank you man
there's a reason why i gravitated
towards it and i feel like we kind of
run the same sort of show we have we
goof around a little more i want to come
out and do yours yeah absolutely we
would love to have you i know you got
stories for days man so you want to
one of the guys i look to look up to the
most so i appreciate you having me thank
you bro um promote anything you'd like
yeah we got our live shows coming up uh
we only do like once a month it's a live
podcast it's not you know stand-up
comedy so uh we will be um in dc at the
end of september we'll be back in new
york in october and then we're going to
do a little west coast swing in november
that's going to go uh
duh
denver phoenix la all right so are you
going to be back
come back in the fall so we'll do it
again we'll run it back and uh you can
see all that go to kfc radio on social
media we have a link in the bio and link
tree for tickets for everything on sale
there so come out and see us do the show
live and subscribe on youtube like
subscribe you know all that nonsense
it's
i hate saying it but it it actually
works and if you don't do it it helps so
much free way to help every show if you
support that also throws it into the
algorithm where other more people more
people see it and you say oh there you
go you're helping us out so really
please do it thank you brother really as
always ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on
all social media we'll talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you